COLE: Man, it's almost
heartbreaking this is gonna go
onto a deck
instead of in the wall,
in the walls in the
house or something.
It's just gorgeous wood.
This western
red cedar is expensive,
but it's light, uh, and
it's really rot resistant so
it won't be no more sloshing
and splashing when the girls
are running around
in circles out here.
Hey Timber.
TIMBER: Yeah?
COLE: I'll have
you be inside today.
I'm gonna have to
pull this whole, all this,
all these bases,
they're all rotten.
TIMBER: Yeah we, we
don't want anyone to go blunk.
COLE: Nope.
We don't need to be swimming
today it's, kind of cold.
TIMBER: Yeah.
COLE: Now, it's
just destroy time.
(grunting)
Oh, geez, that
thing is so rotten.
(laughs)
It's very labor
intensive out here,
to get anything out
here is labor intensive.
It just takes, uh, three times
as long to get anything done,
but all's we got's time.
I ain't dying today.
It's all gotta come up,
everything is rotten and heavy.
Holy.
Every board I pull off I
learn more and more about
how this thing was put
together and, and how to fix it.
I'm tearing up a
part of history,
but I wanna fix it
better than it was.
Camp 36 is kind of the
museum on water and I want to
keep it as close to
the history as I can.
The sea life that's
under here is just amazing.
It's crazy.
You know, I got
sea stars, and mussels,
and all sorts of
things under here,
we're just a floating reef.
Getting close to halfway
done with this teardown,
but the only tricky
part is watching my step
and not going in
between the logs here.
I'd like to get
the framing down,
and just get some boards
throwed down up here so we can,
we can still get around.
COLE: Whoa!
That one's rotten.
Might just be safer
to walk the logs now.
This is eyeball
carpentry all day long.
It's, uh, I don't think
there's a level spot on
this house, but
it's just what it is.
I mean even a house on land,
you gotta replace decking.
It's just the
challenge of it out here is,
you fall in the water if
you fall off the deck, you know.
Contemplating my life
decisions right at this moment.
(grunts)
Dang.
I knew this one
was gonna be tough.
Since my wife left,
I'm out here alone.
Come off of there.
That's the
challenging part of this now,
it's hard to not have that help.
You know, I got the girls
and they help when they can,
but them little
girls aren't gonna pack a,
a four-by-eight post.
Or a beam.
I've gotta do all
the backbreaking work.
But it's also gratifying
to know I don't need anybody.
I don't, I don't
have to have anybody.
I mean I put the beams down,
put my cross braces on.
Look at that.
That works.